and i believe uh sandra's uh talk today
on
optimal collusion free teaching is also
in that same general
area so sandra welcome please go ahead
thank you so much thank you for the kind
introduction and also for the invitation
to speak here today i'm
really hyped about this so as
sanjit said i'm going to talk about
machine teaching so my point of view is
a little bit different because i come
from a different area but
i already see so many um so many
aspects of where where we're thinking in
very similar ways and where i think
there could be synergies
so what i'm talking about today is just
a very very condensed
um summary of a number of papers that
are published with a number of
co-authors listed here on that slide who
might really like to
acknowledge and basically uh what it's
all about is the aspect of
machine teaching where from a machine
learning point of view
we look at tailoring learning algorithms
to the properties of the source that
provides training data rather than just
assuming i've got
randomly chosen data i want to
find out you know if i if i can model
the source that provides the data in a
better way
then perhaps i could be much more
efficient in learning
and i think that um
sushmit's talk already showed that in
the formal verification
and program synthesis uh community
you're actually doing something similar
you're tailoring
the algorithms to properties of oracle's
and i think that's judgment
phrase it this way we design learner and
oracle together
so that's really much very much the kind
of way of thinking that i like and
that's why i think our research kind of
connects
so in my formal learning models that
i'll be talking about today i will
always be assuming
there is some instant space that could
be any set x
and a concept is just a subset of that
instance space a concept class
is a class of concepts the learner will
be presented with labeled examples for
concepts
that means just a pair where x is an
element of the instance space and l
is a label either one or zero depending
on whether or not
x belongs to the concept in this simple
example here x is the euclidean space
and the concept class would be all
orthogonal rectangles and this could be
one
target concept with a bunch of examples
that the learner sees
in computational learning theory we have
lots and lots of formal learning models
and compare them to each other
some of them assume that the source of
information that produces the examples
is some random variable that
somehow follows some real world
distribution one model of uh
random examples is uh the pac model is
very popular
and um the learner then receives these
examples for
the target concept and produces a
hypothesis both
the information source and the learner
do know the whole class of concepts
but of course the learner does not know
which one is the target concept that's
what it's supposed to be figuring out
there are also models where the learner
chooses which examples it will be
presented with so it picks the x's and
it sees the correct labels for them this
is active learning
here the information source is not a
random thing but it's an oracle
and then the model that i'll be looking
at is
a model of a teacher that is benevolent
and
chooses the examples in some helpful way
and in particular i will look at only
exact
learning so we're not approximating the
target concept we want to identify it
exactly
why would you ever consider something
like machine teaching
so there are relations for one thing to
several other research areas as you know
the reason i'm here is because we all
believe there's relations to model
checking program synthesis
there are relations to robot robot
interaction
programming by demonstration or
programming by example are keywords
where
a teacher plays a role and also on the
interface between computer science and
psychology
people study machine teaching and i have
some people who work in
in both fields and and use concepts uh
from one in in the connection of the uh
in the context of the other field so
that's quite interesting too
also within computational learning
theory it relates to
other topics such as sample compression
active learning
whenever we study sample complexity
notions of
teaching do come up and at the end of
the day
we always ask ourselves how small a
training data set
is sufficient for learning so how how
small can the teacher make the number of
examples so that the learner can still
identify the target concept correctly
the classical notion of teaching
goes back to the early 90s several
research groups have worked on it
independently that's the teaching
dimension notion
here to teach a con concept really means
to provide
a set of labeled examples which we call
a teaching set
t of c all these examples are labeled
correctly for c so there's no noise
and the teaching set tfc has to disagree
with all the other concepts in the class
so that it really uniquely identifies
the target concept there's a
corresponding
complexity parameter called the teaching
dimension the teaching dimension of a
concept c
with respect to the class c is just
simply the smallest possible size of
such teaching set
and the teaching dimension of the class
is just the worst case teaching
dimension taken over all the concepts
for example if the concepts are circles
in the
euclidean space with positive radius so
just the circular
lines not the interior and you can teach
any concept with three examples by just
putting them
um taking three positive examples so
three
points on the circle then of course
there's only a single
unique circle that contains those three
points therefore the teaching dimension
here in that case is three
because it's also easy to see that less
than three points won't be sufficient
however if we now fill these circles if
we make them filled balds
with positive radius and the teaching
dimension is infinite if we do
really exact learning not approximating
because obviously
no matter how many positive examples i
put into that orange ball and no matter
how many
negative ones i put outside the orange
ball you can always squeeze
another ball in between that is
consistent so hence you cannot
teach them exactly
now to overcome the limitations of that
classical teaching model
people have looked at notions of
cooperative teaching and learning where
the idea is
you know in the classical teaching model
the teacher assumes that the learner is
stupid in the sense that all it does is
produce a concept that is consistent
with the example scene
now if the learner instead knows
something more about the selection
process
that the teacher uses then it can make
stronger inferences and
therefore learn faster and
that is also supported by psychology and
humans do actually do that they are
sensitive to the way observations are
sampled
there's been a number of models in the
literature on
that that use this cooperative i.t idea
baibach was one of the first introducing
such a model but we also had the
recursive teaching model
about 10 years ago these models
they overcome some of the limitations
but they still don't work well for
geometric
concepts over the real numbers so
when we design a new teaching model
there is one thing that we always have
to
uh look at is is somehow we we can't
just
design it freely we have to somehow set
constraints limitations
on what's allowed so in particular we
want to avoid
some kind of collusion between the
teaching a learner and it's not
obvious how to model or define what is
collusion
what is not here's an example uh you
could ask yourself why wouldn't i simply
teach
such a ball with two points namely the
center point and the north pole that
would make a nice teaching set
and then the learner could um knowing my
selection process
just uh figure out what i've what i'm
trying to teach
that's fine but now imagine i've picked
these teaching sets and
um for this orange ball i throw in an
extra an additional example
you know i give you more information and
then
then the set then then the teaching set
i throw in this third point now
obviously the problem is
am i teaching you this orange ball or am
i teaching you this red ball
because with these three points you
don't know which one is the center of
the
target concept so if you
were to use a center point
and north pole we could call we would
call that a collusion
because what happens is if you add
additional correct
examples you're going to confuse the
learner that's something
that we want to disallow that is
a notion introduced by goldman and
matthias in the 90s
that notion of collusion free teaching
so here uh a teacher learner pair
um consists obviously if a teacher
teaches a mapping that maps every
concept
in the class to a set of labeled
examples that are
labeled correctly with respect with
respect to the concept c
the learner uh is successful only if it
decodes the teaching set for c again to
c
and that pair is called collusion free
on that concept class
if the following holds whenever i add
more examples to a teaching set for c
that are and the examples are all
consistent with c then it will
not throw the learner off the learner
will still say c
and that is not the only uh notion of
collusion freeness that you could
envision
but it's the most uh most
uh often adopted one in the literature
just maybe because it's uh it was the
first one to be proposed and it
it happens to be the case that lots of
models do
uh fulfill this notion for example the
teaching dimension model obviously
satisfies this collusion freeness notion
also the recursive teaching model that i
introduced or not introduced but
mentioned before
satisfies this notion of collusion
freeness so it and it seems to
intuitively make sense it seems to be a
reasonable
requirement so then you can ask yourself
um in particular because in the
literature there have been
many models proposed that meet this
notion of collusion freeness
what's the best possible you could do
for uh for this constraint
what's the best possible teaching rule
that you could devise
so that is something that we answered a
couple years ago with
actually it's very very simple um and
the
both the idea and the proof are just a
few lines
a teacher for a concept class c can
only then be paired with a learner that
is
successful and doesn't use and the both
two of them don't use collusion
not only if but if and only if for any
two concepts in the class we have the
following property
the teaching set for c2 is inconsistent
with c1
or the teaching set for c1 is
inconsistent with c2
so one of them can be consistent with
the other
as long as it doesn't go both ways we
call this
the no clash property so a teacher with
this property is non-clashing
that term was used in a for a very
similar notion in the context of sample
compression
earlier and
this non-clashing teaching is provably
the optimal thing
you can do as long as you said the
teacher satisfies this constraint
it is an optimal teacher under the
notion of collusion freeness
and in the example of center point a
north pole
obviously you do have a clash here
because the teaching said for the red
ball
and the teaching set for the orange ball
they you know they would be
consistent in both directions so that
would be a clash
and that wouldn't be allowed so the null
clash
teaching dimension is then defined in a
very similar way as the
teaching dimension before if we have a
teacher mapping t we say the order of
that teacher mapping is just the
worst case teaching set size that it
produces and the no clash teaching
dimension
is the best possible worst case
uh teaching set size for all the
non-clashing teachers on a concept class
and therefore the no clash teaching
dimension
is the is exactly the best
possible uh worst case teaching
complexity that you can have in goldman
and matthias's collusion freeness notion
as an example when you have a finite
instance space
x the null clash teaching dimension of
the power set over x
is half the size of x i drew just a
little example here for four instances
16 concepts
we don't have to go into the details um
but there's one thing that bugged
us about the no clash teaching dimension
when we studied it and that was a
funny uh ambiguity effect
that we observed so here's a very simple
concept class four instances
four concepts the concepts are just
intervals of links two on this domain
if we look at this concept class here um
i've marked in red a potential choice of
non-clashing teaching
sets you see uh there are two concepts
that are consistent with this
c1 and c4 with this uh with this notion
that x1 is one there are two that are
consistent
but c4 has as teaching said
x4 is one so it's inconsistent with c1
and therefore there is uh
no clash here so you can choose these
teaching sets and not have a clash but
you can also take the second positive
example for each concept
and also not have a clash it's the same
um
same thing so this is just a copy again
of the same matrix you see
two different assignments of teaching
sets to concepts are clash free
and actually the range that that the two
teachers use is exactly the same
they use exactly the same sets but
encode something different so they're
somehow teacher learner must
disambiguate between that
so is that some additional form of
collusion that isn't
isn't captured in the notion proposed by
goldman and matthias
so we therefore oh sorry we therefore
defined a
different notion a stricter notion of
collusion freeness which we called on
ambiguity
a teacher is unambiguous on a concept
class c
if for every finite subclass
and every teacher um that is different
from t
on that finite subclass the two of them
um uh they cannot have the same range
okay and um
this example here shows that there are
concept classes
for which actually no unambiguous
teacher
can have order of nctd so this is a
really stricter notion of collusion
freeness than the previous one
and what we found out is that the best
possible model
under our unambiguity notion is actually
one that was published already
in the literature by ourselves so the
preference-based teaching dimension
model
is a model that that is optimal with
respect
to this uh notion of unambiguity in
preference based teaching
teacher and learner first agree on a
preference relation over concepts
that induces a partial order over the
concept class
now to teach a concept in the classical
teaching dimension model means to
provide a teaching set of labeled
examples consistent with a concept
in a way that the teaching set disagrees
with all the other concepts
now we're saying the teaching set
disagrees with
all other concepts that are
no less preferred than c another
preference relation
so if concept c prime is less preferred
than c
it's fine if it's consistent with a
teaching set because it's less preferred
the teacher will not output the learner
will not output it
okay only the higher the more preferred
ones i have to worry about
and again we can define a preference
based teaching dimension parameter
the size of the smallest teaching set
for a concept under a given relation
that would be the preference based
teaching dimension for that concept
for the concept class again it's the
worst case
and um now i can define the preference
based teaching dimension of the concept
class to be
the smallest possible value that i would
get over all
prefer allowed preference relations
and what you get then is
for example with the balls a very
intuitive teaching set
you recall the teaching dimension is
infinite but if we now prefer
circles with smaller radius over those
with larger radius then we can teach
with only two examples for the orange
ball here i'll
show it i pick two positive examples
that are diametrically opposed
obviously the green ball is consistent
but it's less preferred because it has a
larger radius
obviously the orange ball is the unique
uh ball
the unique most preferred ball that is
consistent with these examples so that
gives us a very simple
and intuitive teaching set in that case
and the result that i promised before if
we take any concept class
um then the preference based teaching
dimension
is really the best possible
teaching complexity of any unambiguous
teacher for that concept class
now one thing that we care about a lot
in in my community
is comparing these teaching complexity
notions to one another
and also to complexity parameters that
are studied elsewhere
and for example in the context of
learning from randomly chosen examples
the most popular uh or best known
uh complexity parameter in learning
theory is probably the vc dimension that
nick chernink's dimension
it's uh defined to be the size of the
largest finite subset of the instance
space
such that the concept class will realize
all
potential bit patterns over that uh
over that subset and
and it is a parameter that really
describes
the sample complexity of pac learning
because
that that sample complexity is linear in
the vc dimension
now we've been asking ourselves can we
relate the teaching complexity
to the complexity of learning from
randomly chosen examples so can we
relate our parameters
to the vc dimension it was proven four
years ago
that uh the preference based teaching
dimension is upper
is upper bounded by a function that's
quadratic in the vc dimension but we
don't know
can we get linear we know it's not upper
bounded by vc dimension itself
because preference based teaching
dimension can exceed vc dimension
by a factor of at least five over three
i heard
just last week i was at the alt
conference and
somebody told me oh we think we have a
proof
that the pbtd is at most two times the
vc dimension that would be
nice but i'm still waiting to see that
proof so that would be cool
the no clash teaching dimension is
obviously less than or equal than the p
uh pbtd because uh it is the optimal one
that is
collusion free in the goldman matthias
sins and so it's also
upper bounded by this quadratic function
but we don't know a single class yet
where ncdd
exceeds vc dimension so it could even be
that vcd itself is an
upper bound we've also been trying to
compare nctd
and pbtd the largest observed gap we've
found so far is
examples where pptd is four times nctd
but we believe that it can actually be
arbitrarily large the problem is it's
very hard to
set up computer experiments to construct
such classes and test them
because of uh the nctd being
being a bit of a beast in that regard
because uh we
it's it's easy no not easy to but we can
show
that the nctd um
whether the nctd is one is already np
complete
to the side and um
also whether nctd is less than or equal
to k for any number k
is an np complete problem and by
contrast the same questions for pbtd
can be decided in polynomial time so
there's
actually an interesting link to graph
theory so the proof
that's the proof for this nctd result is
though at least the one we have is not
trivial at all
but it makes a nice connection to the
theory of matching
so what we have what you can imagine is
just a bipartite graph
the black vertices are concepts the red
vertices
are sets of labeled examples
and you draw an edge if a set of labeled
examples
is consistent with a concept now
if these are all uh sets of size one
then to have a a teacher uh
um a teacher mapping that maps to
that has order one you would have to
find
a matching that assigns a teaching set
to each of these vertices here
and in no clash teaching
not matching cannot have a four cycle of
this kind
if i were to assign this this set
to this concept this set to this concept
i would have a clash
because these show that i have
mutual consistency so these four cycles
are not allowed and we didn't find
any complexity results about that
particular matching problem in the
literature but we
managed to construct a um a reduction
proof that shows it as
np complete 2 and then have actually
lots of interesting matching results as
well to accompany this
so to conclude uh we've seen that no
clash teaching is
the optimal collusion free teaching
model in that goldman matthias sense
preference-based teaching is optimal in
terms of unambiguity
there are some interesting relationships
between we see dimension and sample
complexity
uh learning from uh from random examples
and and
of learning from teachers on the other
side but there's a bunch of open
questions
can we bound the nctd above by vc
dimension or a function linear and we
see dimension
as the pbtd bounded above by a function
linear in the vc dimension
and how large is the gap between those
two
and one thing that i i'm thinking about
a lot is
applications and i think the preference
based teaching model is
maybe more interesting for applications
in the nctd
not just because of the hardness results
on nctd but i think
that this notion of preference relation
often is quite intuitive and humans
may use something like a preference
relation i see lots of colleagues trying
to
impose priors on hypothesis spaces
and i think way that that's overkill
right i don't need a
prior that's like a quantitative uh
notion saying this this concept is so
and so much
more likely than that one uh why not
just
say well it is you know more probable or
more preferred
than that one maybe that eases things a
lot maybe there are also some natural
or helpful preference relations that
could be deployed
by oracles and verification and
synthesis so that could be something
interesting
to discuss with you guys at some point
yeah that's my
two cents on on preference
based versus snow clash teaching and i
thank you very much for your attention
and i hope you have some questions
sandra
very very interesting talk um let me
kick off the q a with a question of my
own
um so uh just to understand the
pbtd notions right when you say pbtd of
a concept class c
you take the worst case over all
possible relations correct
no the best best relationship you take
the best relation okay that's what
that's
okay so that's why it's so much more
compact than the teaching dimension
right yeah i see and so and
the rationale there is that it's because
the teacher and the learner are sharing
this
relation in advance right um
so if they yeah so unfortunately in the
infinite case
uh they do have to share this in advance
but
the nice thing is when the concept class
is finite
there is a canonical relation that they
can
always use and that is very nice um
so in the finite case they don't have to
share any information at all about
the relation that they use okay okay and
that makes it i think
uh more applicable because um
yeah i i'm i'm bugged by this by this
problem with the with the infinite
uh infinite concept classes but
uh um i think in many applications you
can get away with a finite concept class
and then then that problem completely
goes away but that's a very good
question
thank you um and so we have a couple of
questions in the chat and q
a so from from marcel last question
do we do we know how stable learning is
with reference relations
uh that is if i put up the relation do
things still work out
oh that's a cool question so um
i haven't really looked into that but i
can very well
imagine that i could uh concoct an
example where things could go
really really wrong if i just make a
very little
change to the preference relation i
would believe
that for certain natural types of
classes and relations
it won't hurt too much and what i would
also think is that if
one could probably
move into a world of approximate
learning rather than
exact learning where you could come up
with
something very much inspired by the
preference based teaching model
where you have more stability or
robustness to those changes but in this
very
very exact strict model that i proposed
i am pretty sure i
could come up with something where a
little change can have a really bad
effect
okay great and there's one more question
from sebastian youngest
uh for preference-based learning do you
know
additional facts about the best relation
yeah as i said in the in the finite case
i do in a finite case i don't have to
think about this at all in the infinite
case it can be really bad
very hard to come up with this so
sometimes when we want to
prove lower bounds and preference-based
teaching to mention in the infinite case
it can be very very tricky because it's
so hard to
argue that this is the best possible um
preference relation
you could possibly have in the finite
case
it it all uh collapses to something
uh very inter very simple so basically
you would give um
you would give the lowest preference to
the concept that has the smallest
classical teaching dimension
so if there's a concept in the class
that can be taught with
two examples and all the others cost
more
then that concept you're actually going
to teach with those two examples
uh so you give it low preference because
you can get
you can have a really cheap teaching set
for it
the other concepts that are
that need larger teaching sets in the
classical model
they have a higher preference so that
you can then give smaller teaching sets
for them
and it's it's very easy to prove that
this always works out and always gives
you the best
possible teaching it's like a you could
do a recursive
kind of peeling off of the simple
concept so you first
yeah you first assigned there was a
follow-up
from the same questioner is the
preference ordered always a linear order
uh no it doesn't uh it doesn't have to
be
so in the finite case of course you can
always uh
but it doesn't have to be no you can
have uh
you in in the finite case you can do
that but in general in the infinite
cases
so all that's important is that it uh
induces a partial order
okay okay excellent thank you so much
sandra
um and so i thank you yeah and uh
um we'll take a very quick uh four
minute break now
uh so get up stretch your legs uh and
we'll see you back
at uh 40 past the hour
for our next two talks